I know you' are wondering when this is going to end. We're almost done,
we're almost done. Let's consider what happens when the first example comes.
This is a negative example as indicated by the red outline.
Because the negative example, we must specialize in most journal
characterization, in such a way that this negative example is dueled out,
and this specialization is consistent with. The most journal version,
starting from the most specialized concept characterization.
The only specialization of this journal concept, that both excludes this and
is consistent with this node is, Sam's cheap. It excludes this,
because it is cheap here, it will rule out the fact that this is expensive here.
Now the agent noticed that these two particular consequences positions
are the same and if a convergence has occurred. Now we have the answer we
wanted. I get allergies whenever I go to Sam's and have a cheap meal.